bonsoir bienvenue dans le 7-8 week-end
le magazine qui vous donne des idées
pour vos loisirs ce soir nous parlerons
musique et expositions dans l'émission
il sera également question de sport et
puis de théâtre avec mon ami à mon
invité berlin pinet bonsoir mais tout
d'abord on ouvre une page exposition
direction la maison félix à montigny le
bretonneux ou ensemble on se retrouve
cet aquarelliste une exposition qui
porte un joli non méli mélo c'est
logique pour une telle technique
105 tableau cette année de travail et
beaucoup d'eau c'est ce qu'il a fallu
aux cet aquarelliste amateurs pour
monter l'exposition méli mélo entre
portraits paysages mais aussi lave
vaisselle et ponceuse des tableaux qui
n'ont pas fini de surprendre on a mis en
place cette exposition par en se basant
sur les couleurs en fait on a fait des
zones de couleur
identique ou presque
pour que ce soit plus agréable à l'oeil
il ya des endroits où vous avez beaucoup
de bleu des orangers là où une salle où
vient beaucoup de portraits dans des
mauvais depuis sept ans les peintres se
retrouvent assidûment tous les mercredis
soir à la villa simone signoret à
guyancourt autour d'une professeur ils
affinent leurs techniques à l'atelier ou
chez eux ils travaillent avec la même
minutie sur leur tableau au début on
commence par des choses un petit peu
classique sur un petit peu peur de se
lancer et puis après
on cherche des choses un peu pas plus
particulière faye après feuilles année
après année ils ont appris à maîtriser
un art complexe c'est une grande
aventure avec l'eau l'aquarelle c'est à
dire que c'est
et on travaille beaucoup beaucoup dans
l'eau qu'on ne maîtrise pas toujours et
parfois on a l'idée de faire quelque
chose mais ça ne devient pas forcément
ce qu'on a décidé il faut improviser
avec ce qui se passe au niveau d'une
feuille
l'exposition est à découvrir à la maison
félix à montigny le bretonneux jusqu'au
dimanche 1er février avec une nocturne
jusqu'à 21h ce vendredi
on va quitter l'univers de l'aquarelle
pour un autre votre univers bonsoir
bernard pinet bons joueurs et un
comédien jaillir complet parce que vous
êtes à la fois comédien de cinéma de
théâtre de télévision vous êtes auteur
aussi et si on vous accueille ce soir
c'est parce que d'abord vous êtes
libinois de noisy le roi et vous allez
jouer ce samedi soir votre pièce
pétanque et sentiments à gambais dans
les yvelines c'est une espèce de retour
aux sources les igloos oui c'est demain
soir à 20h30 tessa le louis va sous que
pétanque et sentiment va poursuivre son
aventure qui a démarré il ya dix ans ah
oui à 250 de 5250 à nous nous approchons
des trois présentations
voix la liste un spectacle qui concerne
tout le monde qui est populaire mais non
populiste il concerne les jeunes les
anciens les intellos les
les manuels les femmes les hommes sas
met en exergue de toutes les
problématiques que l'on rencontre au
cours de son histoire personnelle on va
parler de cette caisse pétanque et
sentiments ça c'est de le livrer vous
l'avez dit 1 250 représentations ça a
été joué plus de 100 fois au théâtre de
la huchette vous êtes venu au moins
moyenne par deux fois à versailles ça a
été joué aussi au festival d'avignon
c'est pour dire que le tour de bien
c'est quatre fois en avignon la réunion
et les critiques sont sont bonnes oui de
pétanque et sentiments c'est une comédie
d'amour amour avec à metz
une comédie d'amour avec d'abord l'amour
en général nous concerne tous heureux je
l'espérais ensuite une comédie d'amour
au pluriel concernant cette pièce en
trois actes parce que c'est c'est
l'amour entre un homme une femme c'est
l'amour entre
un homme et son chien c'est l'amour
entre un homme et ses clients il un
petit bar dans un lieu qui n'est pas
défini dans le spectacle une époque qui
n'est pas tout à fait précise et
l'accueil des personnalités qui font
écho à tous les atouts le casting de la
comédie humaine qu'est ce qui vous a
donné envie d'écrire cette pièce parce
qu'elle a vécu depuis un petit moment
que cette prouesse elle a fêté ses dix
ans le mi novembre salle jacques brel
demande de la ville
c'est le septième spectacle seul en
scène que je fais parce que je lis à 4
14 personnages mais il ya un personnage
principal qui donnent vie aux autres par
la magie du verbe et le jeu de l'acteur
c'est issu d'un des spectacles
précédents dans lequel il y avait un
texte je faisais des petites fictions un
cumul de fiction qui parlait d'un
tournoi de pétanque
etc jean françois fonlupt producteurs
bien connu qui était patron de siby 2000
la branche cinéma tf1 que quatre palme
d'or à cannes - qui m'a dit mais tu
devrais tu devrais développer ce nice
une structure de théâtre de comédie
c'était un très bon conseil gelé suivi
et c'est devenu patent que les
sentiments continue de parler avec vous
regardez un extrait c'est encore le plus
simple pour se donner une idée on
regarde
car dans
les toilettes au vous pourriez demander
gentiment
faut être poli en effet la dame pipi
et puis si c'est un café aux faucons
sommeil a pétri cabinet npa
d'après elle
il paraît que ne passent plus de temps à
tirer sur les terrains de boules
lapuente à la maison
la tête
bonjour monsieur le commissaire toujours
là des ouvertures fidèle au poste la
police
c'était le jour du pique nique de la
saint valentin
j'aurais dû me méfier piqué nique
c'est un double si
vous avez dit un seul spectacle vous
l'avez jouer ça va faire commencer à
jouer la première fois c'était en 2004
au théâtre michel à paris c'était pas la
répétition générale en disant est ce que
le spectacle a évolué forcément oui oui
oui sans aucun doute d'ailleurs les
extraits que j aime voir je sais pas où
vous les avez sur internet chez oui mais
bon ils sont réels injection n'y a pas
de
cet extrait d'une version du spectacle
qui est déjà un certain temps et bien
sûr qu'il a évolué pour sait déjà que ça
évolue dans l'écriture c'est à vous de
réalise en scène ça évolue forcément
quand on est acteur on évolue en dix ans
dont cinq qui évolue donc tout puisque
en plus en ce qui me concerne j'en suis
l'auteur interprète et metteur en scène
donc j'ai j'ai les manettes de tous de
tous les outils
l'expérience le temps l'âge
qu'est ce que ça fait justement l'âge la
réflexion ya des répliques que vous avez
écrite en 2004 qui ont convolé regarder
dix ans plus tard
on change et qu'on vous certaines n'y
sont plus d'autres les ont remplacés
c'est fait pour ça le temps pour polir
son travail quel qu'il soit pour polir
sa vie quel qu'il soit c'est très utile
le temps une expérience vous êtes une
comédie en trois actes comment on
conserve la même énergie en disant
gauche de cette pièce de 155 au mans
conserve la même énergie c'est très
simple parce que je suis comme tous les
êtres humains de ces petites planètes on
n'est jamais même chaque jour chaque
jour on a des nouveaux soucis une
nouvelle énergie de nouvelles envies
biais de nouveaux désespoir de nouvelles
émotions de nouvelles joies bon déjà ça
s'éteint c'est concret et puis on n'a
jamais le même public chaque soir un
public différent qui lui aussi a ses
soucis et les noces qui se consomme
entre le public et l'artiste sont
différentes une noce est différente
chaque soir quand donc la règle son du
piano comme un couple oui
et ça veut dire que de la façon dont
réagissent public c'est aussi une façon
pour pour l'acteur d'être d'avoir plus
ou moins d'énergie parce que publics ne
réagissent pas de la même manière
jamais jamais c'est une réactivité
incertaine et fort heureusement
l'artiste aussi jamais à 100% le même il
est un diapason qui doit adopter
s'adapter à la mélodie qui se met en
place chaque soir dans la salle du
spectacle quand on écrit comme ça une
pièce où on doit faire rire on doit
amuser on doit distraire comme on arrive
à trouver les bons mots
c'est du travail dans beaucoup de
travail à moins de temps pour moi oui ça
a pris beaucoup de temps et a
probablement des personnes qui ont cette
faculté mais sept spectacles m'ont pris
du temps les livres que j'écris en ce
moment le prennent du temps c'est
d'abord un plaisir ensuite au enfin en
ce qui me concerne je peux pas parler au
nom de tous les auteurs mais en ce qui
me concerne je je je pars jamais d'une
feuille blanche pour dire je vais faire
rire je vais faire pleurer ou je vais
faire ce que je veux faire ça non on
part d'une histoire on
on construit un canevas un châssis un
squelette et puis on y met de la matière
de la chair humaine spirituelle et puis
une alchimie comme ça qui se fixe au fil
du temps qui va bouger au moment des
répétitions qui va qui va bouger sur la
durée des représentations ccc un voyage
étrange et mystérieux mais passionnant
voyage étrange mystérieux
d'humour mais aussi d'émotion a bien sûr
je veux dire toute personne qui peut
faire lire qui sait faire rire c'est
forcément pleurer on ne peut pas rire si
on n'a pas pleuré
rien n'est facile en ce moment
mais de maintenir une constante de joie
et de rire de tout et surtout de soi
c'est un exercice plus un peu plus
subtil me semble-t-il donc ça samedi
soir avant mai à 20h30 donc pétanque et
sentimentalement grèce ou
du château trompette tout à fait à
bordeaux qui s'affiche mais comme ça
merci voir ça il yad'autres la suite
pour vous oui alors face pétanque et
sentiments ça a continué sa retraite il
a encore bien compris que c'est c'est
une pièce qui est déjà été joués 250
fois et qu'il sera continué à être jouée
mais est ce que vous venez vous avez
aussi d'autres projets oui là nous
sommes en train de préparer le montage
d'une pièce qui s'appelle les copies
anonymes avec jean jacques thibaud qui
est mon co auteur sur les copies
anonymes qui devrait secret à paris je
pense dans les mois qui suivent j'ai un
livre sur l'alchimie un spectacle sur
l'alchimie qui se prépare
si non pas scientifique philosophique et
spirituelle dans la notion d'intellect
et de culture donc qui sera très
différente pétanque y sentiments mais où
il y aura j'ose l'espérer des pointes
d'humour mais dd comme dans pétanque et
sentiments du sens et des valeurs qui
nous concerne tous cas merci beaucoup
d'être venu sur les 7,8 ce week-end nous
parler de pétanque et sentiment que vous
jouez donc ce samedi soir à granby salle
louisa louis vachon rue du château
trompette merci de m'avoir aussi vers
ses locaux à bernard pinet on poursuit
ce magazine avec une page musique
maintenant
la maîtrise d'enfants d'autres apps sera
en concert ce dimanche à l'école de
musique de la vie dans le cadre de la
clôture de la semaine du son à un moment
évidemment très important pour eux il
était d'ailleurs en répétition ce mardi
soir la résidence fourcassa attrape des
images signées louise mbo ide et patrick
jacques de dixmude
donc pour le coeur des gens ont commencé
à écouter
dernier conseil dernier placement
gabrielle est la chef de choeur à l'oeil
elle veut que tout soit parfait pour que
toutes les notes s'enchaînent
correctement comme des professionnels
les enfants de la maîtrise de trappes
font leur exercice verticalité
ce soir là il donne une représentation à
la résidence pour personnes âgées
fourcassa à train
se faire plaisir et faire plaisir je
crois au aux personnes âgées aussi qui
qui aiment la musique pour nous c'est
une expérience de plus en petit comité
de s'entraîner et de faire des choses
devant public mais j'aime chanter
et j'aime bien le genre musical c'est
surtout vient de santé devant des
personnes âgées parce que ce temps ça
vient je suis très très bien ils sont
bien accompagner et tout c'est agréable
c'est la vie les enfants
la maîtrise d enfant de trappes a vu le
jour en 2011 à l'initiative du projet de
la paix msq l'association pour la
promotion de la musique à saint quentin
en yvelines l'apn est ce qu va là où
peut-être d'autres n'osent pas
intervenir dans les quartiers populaires
là où la musique n'a pas toujours
naturellement sa place il y a 4 ans 5
enfants ont posé l'année crise
aujourd'hui ils sont une trentaine de 7
à 16 ans
parmi les interpréter ce soir là la
neuvième symphonie de dvorak accompagné
d'un message de paix qui enfin le froid
et la forme dans leurs yeux la frayeur
au tour de l'horreur est partout la
misère le matri enfants arrêter cette
guerre au monde
ces textes existent depuis 25 ans
maintenant depuis que j'enseigne aux
enfants et malheureusement c'est
toujours actuelle et c'est toujours
aussi émouvants c'est une période où il
faut il faut témoigner aussi
par les chants et par les enfants que
voilà on est on est coup contre de tous
ces choses qui nuit notre belle vie les
enfants de la maîtrise seront en concert
ce dimanche à l'auditorium de l'école de
musique de trappes ils seront
accompagnés de l'orchestré manifestants
je vous pose maintenant deux dates à
retenir la saxophoniste géraldine
laurent se rend trio ce samedi soir au
prisme à elancourt les places sont à
partir de 9 euros en 2006 et géraldine
laurent a reçu le django d'or du jeune
talent elle se produit notamment avec
aldo romano henri texier ses influences
sony rollix eric dolphy on écoute
et on continue en musique avec barbara
hendricks des sources du jazz en passant
par le blues la chanteuse sera sur la
scène du prisme à elancourt le mardi 4
février à 21h les places sont à 43 euros
une figure incontournable
je passe
oh
alors
en cette fin de semaine avec une météo
qu'on annonce un petit peu maussade quoi
de mieux que de faire un tour au cinéma
et pour vous éclairer sur la dernière
sortie je vous propose de voavy de
spectateurs c'est bien évidemment au
micro d' elodie moines qui a ses
habitués c'est un super film d'actualité
d'ailleurs c'est en plein dans
l'actualité c'est savoureux dont les
acteurs sont bons
voilà ça charmant film savoir il est
très très bien ce très beau film qui
dément toute l'eau du finning tension
subtil et très beau film
une partie de l'histoire que je
connaissais pas personnellement donc ça
m'a vraiment touché c'est vraiment un
film génial un super biopic
quand on pense à l'histoire de cet homme
c'est incroyable ce qu'il a fait c'est
très british j'adore j'adore cet humour
en choeur génial j'étais un très beau
film bonne mise en scène
une reconstitution historique
trendy c'est un film excellent et le
performance de
dominique 9 heures de combat match était
superbe ça bien que traduit le caractère
un peu triste mais très intelligent de
deux lames du riz et je vous propose
maintenant le coup de coeur d'un
professionnel du septième art ce soir
cyril à haddad de l'espace philippe
noiret des clayes-sous-bois
cette semaine le coup de coeur de
l'espace philippe noiret et le film
whiplash réalisé par damien chazelle
andrew 19 ans rêve de devenir l'un des
meilleurs batteurs de jazz de sa
génération la concurrence est rude au
conservatoire de manhattan où il
s'entraîne avec acharnement il a pour
objectif d'intégrer le fleuron des
orchestres dirigés par terence fisher
professeur féroce et intraitable lorsque
celui-ci leur père enfin andrew se lance
sous sa direction dans la quête de
l'excellence
se démarquant du film musical habituel
whiplash est inspiré de l'histoire
personnelle du réalisateur ce dernier si
un premier film a le temps et relevant
quasiment du thriller temps il est plein
de suspense dans le parcours de ce jeune
musicien enthousiaste confronté à un
mentor despotique le film est une
véritable décharge émotionnelle bâti sur
la persévérance et l'abnégation
c'est un pur moment de cinéma bien trop
rares pour ne pas foncer tête baissée
whiplash est à découvrir cette semaine
sans hésitation à l'espace fixe n'aurait
on a presque à la fin de cette émission
en maintenant par les sports avec vous
mais calendo bonjour alors bonjour
catherine alors donné des idées c'est ça
alors est ce que vous êtes une amatrice
de sport
alors vous allez être servis ce week-end
alors on commence tout d'abord par du
basket ce sera le rendez vous sports
incontournable dans les yvelines trappe
reçoit le chesnay-versailles ce samedi à
20 heures au gymnase paul maillet un
derby toujours aussi bouillonnant les
trappistes s'étaient facilement imposés
au match aller en dominant leurs voisins
sur le score de 82 à 65 victoire
impérative pour les deux équipes trap
est actuellement la huitième place du
classement et le chesnay et 11e de
nationale 3 les deux équipes doivent
donc l'emporter pour se maintenir au
rugby victoire impérative pour plaisir
en fédérale 2 les hommes de pierre
vidalis reçoivent tour dimanche à 15
heures au stade robert barran pour le
compte de la 13e journée un match
déséquilibré sur le papier les plaisirs
ou à pointe à une inquiétante 9e place
avec seulement deux victoires depuis le
début de la saison tours est lui
cinquième de cette fédérale 2 avec 34
points on continue à parler rugby encore
rugby toujours en ruine donc
saint-quentin-en-yvelines reçoit clichy
pour le compte de la 14e journée de
promotion d'honneur second classement
les saint quentinois doivent l'emporter
pour rester dans les premières places le
match s'annonce serré ski shit
actuellement à la 4e place du classement
si vous voulez assister à la rencontre
le match est programmé ce dimanche à 15
heures au stade andré boniface heil en
cours et puis donc maintenant football
l'étoile sportive de trappes reçoit
parisienne ce dimanche à 15 heures au
stade robert gravaud il rend compte que
les trappistes doivent impérativement
remporter trappe 9e du classement
flirte actuellement avec la relégation
une victoire contre le 10e parisienne
lui donnerait une bouffée d'oxygène dans
la course au maintien en tennis la ville
le final du 12e open de tennis de la
verrière est programmée ce dimanche à
14h30 pendant deux semaines une centaine
de joueurs se sont affrontés sur les
courts le tournoi est organisé au parc
sportif philippe cousteau
et puis il y aura également du tennis de
table ce week end voisins le bretonneux
organise son 6e tournoi régional ce
dimanche de 9h 15 à 21 heures au gymnase
des pyramides une centaine de pongistes
de toute l'île de france sont attendus
pour l'occasion voilà pour l'agenda du
week end
il ya de quoi faire mais jouer le tennis
de table de 9h15 à 21 heures salle
ajournement si vous êtes fan c'est car
il faut aller à voisins le bretonneux et
je rappelle qu on vous retrouve
évidemment moi cette fuite sport ce sera
lundi en direct à 18h30 on parlera de
hand voilà et on croise les doigts pour
l'équipe de france évidemment pour sa
demi finale ce vendredi soir et on
parlera aussi des templiers d'elancourt
dialambéré saison merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup cette femme de warwick un petit
peu et je compose en tout cas c'est un
jeu de société qu'on peut pratiquer et
ça peut être l'occasion ce week-end
parce qu'il va pas faire très très beau
et si vous voulez en savoir un petit peu
plus je vous propose de regarder ce
reportage il est signé d'un
inconditionnel du warm-up william l
canon laser c'est bien tu es un
jc josiane
cerberus si ces termes ne vous parle pas
du tout c'est normal venez à l'instant
d'entrer dans l'univers de warhammer et
un jeu de plateau ou des joueurs
s'affrontent par armés interposés c'est
un jeu de figurines qui se décline en
deux types d'univers l'univers battles
et l'univers 41 univers battle pour
comparer on peut comparer à l'univers du
seigneur des anneaux où on trouve les
humains les orques les elfes les nains
désordre et à l'univers 40000 qui touche
le plus les côtés de la jeunesse où ça
se passe donc au 40 ème millénaire
ici c'est une partie de 40000 qui est en
train de se dérouler lissac et même si
le fonctionnement paraît simple c'est le
jeu lui ne l'est pas du tout
relativement complète et environ dans
les 150 pages
pour les règles de base et il ya des
règles
complémentaire pour chacune des factions
chaque faction à son propre livre de
règles la faction c'est l'armé d'un
joueur chaque faction est alors
totalement différente les joueurs la
composent en achetant des figurines
qu'il faut d'abord rassembler et puis
peindre de savoir que les figurines avec
lesquels on joue on les a montées en les
assembler pour les uns pinte c'est quand
même un plaisir de jouer ses propres
figures et
là je fais les space marines mais
version black templar peut soit peindre
pour faire des batailles ou soit peindre
pour le plaisir de collectionner les
figures ou de peindre par exemple moi je
pense juste pour les collectionner je
pense qu'on va pas l'événement organisé
par le centre de voisins-le-bretonneux
attire de plus en plus de jeunes chaque
année sur les deux jours 80 personnes
ont fait le déplacement
warhammer un jeu de société conviviale
une véritable discipline pour certains
un championnat du monde et même organisé
tous les ans
ses 7,8 we can est maintenant terminé
merci de l'avoir suivi je vous souhaite
un excellent week-end et je vous dis à
très bien a très vite